hallo sie na wie geht es dir
hallo stefan i mir geht es gut ich bin
gesund und du
ich bin auch gesund ich vermisse den
deutschkurs
ja ich vermisse den deutschkurs auch und
natürlich unsere klasse
ja aber es ist wichtig dass wir alle zu
hause bleiben
so können wir das corona virus schnell
bekämpfen
ganz genau ich gehe nur noch raus wenn
es nötig ist
das ist super was hast du gestern
gemacht
ich bin um 9 uhr aufgestanden
nachdem ich geduscht hatte
habe ich das frühstück für mich und
meinen freund vorbereitet
nachdem ich geduscht hatte
habe ich das frühstück für mich und
meinen freund vorbereitet
danach habe ich meine hausaufgaben
gemacht
ich habe wortschatz training gemacht
super unsere lehrerin hat ja gesagt dass
wir ganz viel wortschatz übungen machen
sollen
super unsere lehrerin hat ja gesagt dass
wir ganz viel wortschatz übungen machen
sollen
genau bevor ich die übungen gemacht habe
hatte ich noch das geschirr abgewaschen
nach den hausaufgaben bin ich für frau
müller einkaufen gegangen
wer ist frau müller
müller ist meine nachbarin
frau müller ist meine nachbarin
sie ist schon 79 jahre alt
sie sollte nicht mehr selber einkaufen
gehen
das ist sehr nett von dir
es ist wichtig dass wir uns jetzt alle
gegenseitig helfen
ich gehe auch für meine schwiegermutter
einkaufen
obwohl sie es eigentlich lieber selber
machen würde
aber sie versteht das ist zu gefährlich
wäre
aber sie versteht dass es zu gefährlich
genau nachdem ich eingekauft hatte habe
ich die lebensmittel für frau müller vor
die türe gestellt
nachdem ich eingekauft hatte habe ich
die lebensmittel für frau müller vor die
türe gestellt
dann habe ich einen film geschaut
habe die untertitel auf deutsch
eingestellt
prima
nach dem film habe ich dann das
mittagessen gekocht
mein freund arbeitet im home office
deshalb konnten wir zusammen zu mittag
essen
mein freund arbeitet im home-office
deshalb konnten wir zusammen zu mittag
essen
oh das ist aber schön
mein mann ist leider so gut wie nicht
mehr zu hause
oh das ist aber schön
mein mann ist leider so gut wie nicht
mehr zu hause
warum warum er ist pfleger
halb muss er jetzt sehr viel arbeiten
er ist pfleger deshalb muss er jetzt
sehr viel arbeiten
ich verstehe
es ist ganz toll was die leute in den
krankenhäusern leisten
ja er ist auch ganz stolz auf sein team
und was hast du nach dem mittagessen
gemacht
nachdem wir gegessen hatten
wäsche gewaschen
und das wohnzimmer gesaugt
nachdem wir gegessen hatten habe ich
wäsche gewaschen
und das wohnzimmer gesaugt
ja ich putze auch jeden tag
ich glaube dass meine wohnung noch nie
so sauber war wie jetzt
ja das ist eine gute beschäftigung in
dieser schweren zeit
und du was hast du gemacht und du was
hast du gemacht
wie gesagt ich habe auch viel geputzt
und ich habe mit meiner familie
telefoniert
ich vermisse sie sehr ich vermisse sie
sehr
ja ich vermisse meine familie auch
wie geht es ihm wie geht es ihnen
im moment gut
meine schwester hilf meiner mutter mit
den einkäufen
so dass sie auch nicht mehr einkaufen
muss
meine schwester hilft meiner mutter mit
den einkäufen so dass sie auch nicht
mehr einkaufen muss
das ist schön
ich muss jetzt das abendessen kochen
sollen wir morgen wieder telefonieren
unbedingt
es tut gut ein bisschen deutsch zu
sprechen
so vergessen wir nicht wie die
aussprache funktioniert
unbedingt
es tut gut ein bisschen deutsch zu
sprechen
so vergessen wir nicht wie die
aussprache funktioniert
absolut wir müssen jeden tag ein
bisschen deutsch sprechen
das hat auch unsere lehrerin gesagt
wir müssen jeden tag ein bisschen
deutsch sprechen
das hat auch unsere lehrerin gesagt
also bis morgen
tschüss stefanie bis morgen
nicht vergessen dieses video zu liken zu
kommentieren und zu teilen